GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME BACK TO
OUR LAST SESSION FOR BUDGETS OF
THREE AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. TODAY, THE RUN OF SHOW
IS. WE'RE GOING TO DO PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR OUR FINAL THOUGHTS,
PRAYERS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS FOR
THE BUDGET, OUR HOPES AND
DREAMS. RIGHT. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO DO THREE VOTES ONLY,
THE FIRST ONE WILL BE WHERE WE
ALL AGREE. THE SECOND WILL BE
WHERE THREE OF US AGREE, AND
THEN NO. YES. AND THE FINAL ONE
WILL BE ALSO THREE OF US AGREE
AND THEN ABSTENTION. SO WE'RE
GOING TO KICK OFF WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. WHERE WE CAN LINE UP
HERE AND THEN WRAP AROUND THE
BACK. FOR ME ALL THE WAY AROUND
THAT, LEAD IT OFF. I'LL, I'LL
KNOW. WHERE ARE YOU UP HERE.
YEAH. NO. YOU'RE FINE. YEAH.
YOU'RE FINE. PLEASE, PLEASE.
YEAH IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT. YEAH? YEAH. SORRY
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
THANK YOU. IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK.
RUSSELL. DAWSON, RAWLINGS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING MANAGER AT
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING, PROGRAMS FOR SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
PARTICULARLY PROTECTING THE
VITAL SERVICES, IN-HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS AND
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR FOOD
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AND,
RESTORING FUNDING FOR CRITICAL
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES, WE KNOW THIS IS A
HARD TIME. WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
STAY STEADFAST AS NEGOTIATIONS
CONTINUE AND WILL BE A RESOURCE
OF SUPPORT AND INFORMATION IF
NEEDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATOR
ROTH, AND I WANT TO THANK
ELIZABETH, WHO'S BEEN A JUST AN
ABSOLUTE WONDERFUL PERSON TO
WORK WITH AND WITH QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS AND ALL THAT. I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE HER WORK. ALSO JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ALL OF
YOU. WHAT YOU'VE DONE AND WHAT
YOU'RE HOPEFULLY GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO, WITH THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
POPULATION. THÀNH JUST ONE NOTE
IN THE UPCOMING, SESSIONS THAT
THAT ARE IN FRONT OF US THAT WE
WORK ON A STABILIZED OPTION FOR
REVENUE FOR THIS POPULATION AND
LOOK AT THAT AS A GET AWAY FROM
THIS ROLLER COASTER OF FUNDING
GOING FORWARD, DUE TO THE LAST
ACT THAT WE INSTIGATED ABOUT 55
YEARS AGO, THAT WE DID SAY THAT
WE WOULD CARE FOR THIS
POPULATION. WE JUST DIDN'T SAY
HOW WELL, AND LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN FOR ALL OF YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION FOR THE
POPULATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. SENATOR ROTH,
CARL LONDON HERE TODAY. I HAVE
TWO QUICK ITEMS TO MENTION. THE
FIRST IS ON BEHALF OF THE SICKLE
CELL DISEASE FOUNDATION AND
CENTER FOR INHERITED BLOOD
DISORDERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
INCLUSION OF THE $5 MILLION IN
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY BUDGET
PROPOSALS YOU PUT FORTH TO
SUPPORT THE SICKLE CELL CENTERS
OF EXCELLENCE THAT WERE MADE
POSSIBLE BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN THE 2019
BUDGET, JUST BRIEFLY, TO REPORT
ON THAT. THOSE 12 CLINICS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT SERVE
10,000 PATIENTS WITH SICKLE CELL
DISEASE HAVE MADE A PROFOUND
DIFFERENCE IN DATA, CONCLUSIVELY
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE PREVENTIVE
CARE BY THESE CLINICS SAVES THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CLOSE TO
$100 MILLION ANNUALLY THROUGH
REDUCED HOSPITALIZATION AND
VISITS TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM. SO
THANK YOU. ON THAT FOR HELPING
ON THAT. SECOND, IS A PARENT
BOARD MEMBER OF A NONPROFIT AND
IS AN ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR PUSHING TO RESTORE THE
RATE INCREASES THAT WE NEED SO
PROFOUNDLY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITHOUT THESE, I
WILL TELL YOU THAT THIS SYSTEM
IS ON THE ABSOLUTE VERGE OF
COLLAPSE. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORT. THANK YOU.
YOU THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. ANDREW SHANE FROM GRACE
END CHILD POVERTY, CALIFORNIA,
ON BEHALF OF THE 750, 765, MOMS
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY. JUST
SO DEEPLY GRATEFUL. YOU KNOW,
I'M PERSONALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
WINDS. A PROGRAM THAT DOESN'T
GET ENOUGH ATTENTION. BUT THAT
ONE I WOULD JUST LIFT UP AS A
SIGN OF THE COMMITMENT ACROSS
THE BOARD OF THIS COMMITTEE, AND
WE KNOW IT'S NOT A LACK OF
SHARED COMMITMENT BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THIS GOVERNOR
HAS BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
CHILDREN. THIS HAS JUST BEEN A
MATTER OF RESOURCES. AND WE
STAND READY TO SUPPORT IN THE
FINAL NEGOTIATIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. ANDREW EILEEN
KAMINSKY WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION, ECHOING
THE GRATITUDE OF THOSE THAT HAVE
COME BEFORE US. THANK YOU TO YOU
ALL AND TO YOUR STAFF FOR ALL OF
THE HARD WORK AND THE
CHAMPIONING ON BEHALF OF
FAMILIES IN DEEP POVERTY, ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND OUR FOSTER
YOUTH, ESPECIALLY, AS WELL, WE
STAND READY TO, TO FIGHT WITH
YOU AS WE ENTER IN THE NEXT
PHASE AND ARE JUST GRATEFUL FOR
ALL YOUR RESTORATIONS.
APPRECIATE IT. THANKS, EILEEN.
ECHOING EILEEN'S COMMENTS, KIM
ROTHSCHILD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN-HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE RESTORED CUTS TO
IHSS. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DARBY KERNAN, ON BEHALF
OF NOURISH CALIFORNIA, WE
SUPPORT THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
ACTION ON MAINTAINING THE
CALFRESH MINIMUM BENEFIT PILOT
AND YOUR ACTION ON THE C FAB
EXPANSION, ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION, WE SUPPORT
YOUR ACTION ON REJECTING THE CAL
WORKS HOME VISITING CUTS AND
YOUR ACTIONS, ON ADDING THE
CHILD CARE SLOTS. AND LASTLY,
LEADINGAGE CALIFORNIA WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
THAT REJECT MANY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CUTS TO THE
HOME SAFE PROGRAM, MULTIPLE
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING AND THE
OTHER OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, KATHY MOSSBERG, ON
BEHALF OF A FEW DIFFERENT
CLIENTS, ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE, REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HELPING US SALVAGE
THE CALIFORNIA CANCER REGISTRY
AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA BRIDGE
CENTER FUNDING ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS FOUNDATION, SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION, APLA HEALTH.
WANT TO REALLY THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL THE SUPPORT
ON THAT PACKAGE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
KEEP ALL OF THAT IN. AND THEN
FINALLY, ON BEHALF OF THE AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING AND MEALS ON
WHEELS, CALIFORNIA, REALLY THANK
YOU TREMENDOUSLY FOR SAVING US
FROM THAT. FROM THE CUT IN
SENIOR NUTRITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KELLY LONGO FLORES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS. WE WORK ALONGSIDE
41 FOOD BANKS ACROSS THE STATE
WITH A MISSION TO END HUNGER.
WE'RE HERE WITH A RESOUNDING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ACTIONS, I
THINK IT SHOWS THE COMMITMENT
AND IT SHOWS THAT YOU WERE
LISTENING TO US, HEARING AFTER
HEARING AS WE WENT THROUGH THESE
JUST A COUPLE OF SPECIFIC ONES I
WANT TO POINT OUT, THANK YOU FOR
PERMANENTLY AUTHORIZING THE
STATE EMERGENCY FOOD BANK
RESERVE. THAT'S HUGE FOR US.
THAT ALLOWS FOOD BANKS TO REACT
REALLY QUICKLY IN TIMES OF
CRISIS. THANK YOU FOR REJECTING
THE ELIMINATION OF THE CAL FRESH
MINIMUM BENEFITS PILOT. AS WE
KNOW, THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
THAT'S $23, UP TO 50, FOR
SUPPORTING CALWORKS AND
REJECTING THE ELIMINATION OF
WINDS. AS ANDREW MENTIONED, I
KNOW IT'S ONLY $10, BUT THAT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE. AND LASTLY, FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN REJECTING THE IHSS
CUTS, ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
LIVE IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT POSSIBLE. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, SARA BACHUS WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN THE COALITION.
SO APPRECIATIVE AND THANKFUL FOR
ALL OF YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
PRESERVING THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM, THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM, THE
CAL WORKS HOME VISITING PROGRAM,
ALL OF THE CHILD CARE PACKAGES
THAT COMPLETE PACKAGE, AND ALSO
ADDING THAT ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION THÀNH PLAN ON THE
ALTERNATE METHODOLOGY, ENSURING
THAT LIVABLE WAGES IS INCLUDED
AS PART OF LIFTING UP THE RATES
FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SO MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. AARON LEVI REPRESENTING
THE CONGREGATE LIVING HEALTH
FACILITY ASSOCIATION, THE
CLIFFS. WE ARE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THE $7.7
MILLION GENERAL FUND INCLUSION.
THIS WILL BE THE FIRST INCREASE
THESE PROVIDERS HAVE HAD IN 40
YEARS, THE FIRST INCREASE EVER.
AND TO REMIND YOU, THESE ARE
YOUNG ADULTS FOR THE MOST PART,
THAT ARE MAINLY QUADRIPLEGIC ON
VENTILATORS. THEY ARE LESS ACUTE
THAN HOSPITALS, BUT MORE ACUTE
THAN NURSING HOMES THAT ARE
LIVING IN A RESIDENTIAL SETTING.
THIS MONEY WILL ALLOW THE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS TO GET THE RAGE
THAT THEY DESERVE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. HELLO, MONICA
KIRKLAND. ON BEHALF OF SENIOR
SERVICES COALITION OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY, WE JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR JUST BEING PARTNERS
WITH ALL OF THIS. WE WANT TO
THANK YOU SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
REJECTIONS, FOR HOME SAFE. WE
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION THÀNH
FOR THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT.
AND NUTRITION IS VERY IMPORTANT
IN JUST PROTECTING THOSE WHO
NEED IT MOST. RIGHT. AND THEN
ALSO FOR THE APS AS WELL AS IHSS
, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT DOES
NOT GO UNRECOGNIZED AS A LOT OF
OUR COLLEAGUES HAS ALREADY
MENTIONED. BUT WE JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MY NAME IS DANITA
STROMGREN AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH AARP REPRESENTING 3.2
MILLION CALIFORNIA MEMBERS,
FIRST, WE'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR REJECTING THIS. THESE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS IN THE MAY
BUDGET REVISION, THE REJECTION
OF THE 111 MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS TO THE OLDER CALIFORNIA
SENIORS NUTRITION PROGRAM
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
THE PROPOSED CUTS OF THE
40,000,000 IN 24, 25 AND ONGOING
FOR ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES,
AS WELL AS THE PROPOSED 4.8
MILLION REDUCTION FOR THE APS
TRAINING, AND FOR THE REJECTION
OF THE DELAY TO THE HOME SAFE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
TO ENHANCE THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM, BUT WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE PROPOSAL
TO IMPLEMENT THE MEDI-CAL SHARE
OF COST REFORM WAS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE PROPOSAL. AND WE URGE
YOUR RECONSIDERATION OF THIS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
EFFORTS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, NORA LYNN, ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW, THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. WE APPRECIATE THE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT MUST BE
MADE, BUT WHEN THINGS GET TOUGH
AND TIGHT, IT IS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE PRIORITIZE
CHILDREN. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
BUDGET PRESENTED BEFORE YOU IS
NOT ONE THAT PRIORITIZES KIDS.
FOR EXAMPLE, IT IS DAMAGING THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THOUSANDS OF ELIGIBLE
YOUNG CHILDREN TO LOSE THEIR
MEDI-CAL COVERAGE EVERY MONTH
BECAUSE OF PAPERWORK, MISTAKES
AND ADMINISTRATIVE ERRORS. IT IS
UNCONSCIONABLE THAT IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOUTH
SUICIDALITY IS AT AN ALL TIME
HIGH, WE ARE REDUCING FUNDS FOR
YOUTH SUICIDE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES. AND WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT WHILE SO MANY NEW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVES
ARE UNFOLDING AND FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE FUNDING STRUCTURE OF
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS, WE ARE CUTTING
SEBIHI EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE
GRANTS, A ONE TIME GRANT PROGRAM
THAT COULD PROVIDE RELIEF AND
STABILITY FOR CBOS SERVING OUR
KIDS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES. WE'D LIKE TO
EXTEND OUR HUGE THANKS TO ALL OF
YOU FOR THE TOUGH WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE ON THE PROPOSALS
BEFORE US THAT IMPACT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH AND FAMILIES,
AND SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO CALL
OUT A FEW SPECIFIC PROGRAMS THAT
WE'RE THANKFUL THAT YOU
RESTORED. ONE IS THE RESTORATION
OF FIRS, WHICH IS A LITERAL
LIFELINE FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH
AND THEIR CAREGIVERS. WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE RESTORATION OF
SOME OF THE PROPOSED WORKFORCE
REDUCTIONS, ESPECIALLY TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE ALREADY
BEEN AWARDED. ALSO GRATEFUL FOR
THE RESTORATION OF THE CAL WORKS
HOME VISITING PROGRAM, AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES PERMANENT RATES
PROPOSAL AS WELL. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT.
THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS, I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
CLIENTS. FIRST, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS, WE
TRULY APPRECIATE THE RESTORATION
OF THE PROVIDER RATE INCREASES
FROM THE MCO TAX REVENUE. THIS
FUNDING WILL HELP PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS ADDRESS OUR 3 TO $4
BILLION DEFICIT AND AVOID
POTENTIAL SERVICE REDUCTIONS.
CAF HAS ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH
DCS TO ADDRESS OUR DEFICIT
THROUGH SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
OUR STATE DIRECTED PAYMENTS,
WHICH USE LOCAL DOLLARS TO DRAW
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS. LARGE
INCREASES TO THESE PROGRAMS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN LIGHT
OF THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE
MCO TAX FUNDING AND THE NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES PROPOSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION. SECOND, ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA,
THE BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS OF LOS
ANGELES, VENTURA, RIVERSIDE,
SANTA CRUZ. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL THE WORK YOU DID TO
AVOID THE DRASTIC CUTS IN HUMAN
SERVICES AND IN IN THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LIVING NETWORK. THANK YOU FOR
REJECTING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES RATE REFORM DELAY. AND
THEN FINALLY, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF DIAPER BANKS,
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY DISAPPOINTED.
AND FOLKS MAY BE ELIMINATING OR
SIGNIFICANTLY CURTAILING
DISBURSEMENT OF DIAPERS, BUT
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT YEAR TO WORK
WITH YOU SOME MORE. THANKS GOOD
MORNING, CHRISTINE SMITH WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA HEALTH
ACCESS APPRECIATES THE
LEGISLATURE'S REJECTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTRATION'S
ELIMINATION OF IHSS BENEFITS
TARGETED AT UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS, CONTINUING THE
GOAL FOR ALL TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS ESSENTIAL SERVICE, AND
CARE. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY FUNDS
COLLECTED FROM THE UNINSURED,
AND WE SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE'S
REJECTION OF THE ONGOING
SWEEPING OF 109 MILLION ANNUALLY
IN FAVOR OF A ONE TIME LOAN.
FUNDS COLLECTED FROM THOSE WHO
ARE UNINSURED SHOULD BE
PRESERVED TO MAKE COVERAGE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL, INCLUDING OVER THE HALF
MILLION UNINSURED UNDOCUMENTED
WHO ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA MARKETPLACE.
BUT THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. JOLIE ONODERA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, REPRESENTING ALL 58
COUNTIES, CSAC IS EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
REJECTION OF THE NUMEROUS
PROPOSED CUTS TO THE CRITICAL
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS, INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH, PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE, CAL WORKS APS,
IHSS AND CHILD WELFARE, VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW VITAL THIS FUNDING IS FOR
COUNTY ADMINISTERED PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS RELY ON
EVERY DAY. THANK YOU. THANKS
GOOD MORNING. MICHELLE GIBBONS
WITH KAYAK REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WANT TO THANK YOU TO
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE, TO YOUR STAFF
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
PROTECTING THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FUNDS. EVERY DAY I'VE
COME INTO THIS ROOM, THERE'S
BEEN A NEW CASE OF SOMETHING
THAT THESE DOLLARS ARE BEING PUT
TO USE TO PREVENT. SO PROTECTING
THESE FUNDS IS PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS. AND SO WE STAND
WITH YOU. WE'LL DO WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
THIS MAKES IT INTO THE FINAL
BUDGET PACKAGE, ALSO JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION ON THE
SYNDROMIC SURVEILLANCE TRAILER
BILL AND THE INTEROPERABILITY
WITH OUR EXISTING SYSTEMS.
APPRECIATION FOR THE CHP
TRANSITION AND HIKE PICNIC AND
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT'S BEING
PROVIDED IN THERE AND FOR
RETAINING THE CAL WORKS HOME
VISITING PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHRISTINE POWELL WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS.
AND WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR
VERY THOUGHTFUL WORK IN THIS
DIFFICULT YEAR, PARTICULARLY IN
THE AREAS OF SUPPORTING CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS BY REJECTING THE
ELIMINATION OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM AND THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL FUNDING AND
PROTECTING THE EMERGENCY CHILD
CARE BRIDGE AND HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
REJECTION OF THE TRIGGER FOR THE
PROPOSED FERM PERMANENT FOSTER
CARE RATE AND THE PROPOSED
REPORTING AND MILESTONES TOWARD
IMPLEMENTATION, AND URGE YOUR
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT AS THAT
PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MY NAME IS JUSTINE
ERPELDING. I'M WITH EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA VOICES AND WE'RE A
MEMBER OF THE COALITION. WE WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. AND
ESPECIALLY THE 11,000 SLOTS THAT
WERE AWARDED THAT YOU HAVE
REQUESTED TO BE HONORED. I GOT
TO SEE THEIR FACES YESTERDAY
WHEN WE HAD PEOPLE HERE
ADVOCATING THAT REPRESENTED 1000
OF THOSE SPOTS THAT YOU'RE
ASKING TO BE RESTORED. WE ALSO
ASK THAT YOU CODIFY THE
REMAINING 200,000 PROMISE SLOTS
SO THAT WE HAVE A TIMELINE OF
WHEN THEY WILL BE RELEASED. BUT
WE ALSO ASK THAT THE DSS TO
CREATE A REPORT THROUGH JANUARY
OF 2026 ON THE ALTERNATIVE
METHODOLOGY, IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRESS AND THAT HOLD HARMLESS
THROUGH 24 AND 25 WILL BE PART
OF THAT. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MALIK BYNUM WITH US
ASKED ME LOCAL 3930 AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN US AND SEIU
ON CHILD CARE. WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SENATE'S
PLAN TO CONTINUE FUNDING THE
OVER 11,000 SLOTS FROM SPRING
2024. HOWEVER, WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS STILL WORK TO BE DONE,
SO WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE
WORKING TOWARDS THAT GOAL OF
200,000 SLOTS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE, AS WELL AS ENSURING
PROGRESS TOWARDS RATE REFORM
BASED ON THE TRUE COST OF CARE.
AS IT RELATES TO HOME CARE. YOU
KNOW, WE'RE ABSOLUTELY GRATEFUL
TO SEE THESE REJECTIONS TO THE
CUTS TO IHSS, SPECIFICALLY THE
EXPANSION TO UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS AND THE ELIMINATION
OF THE PROVIDER BACKUP SYSTEM,
BOTH CRITICAL PIECES OF THE
PROGRAM FOR CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDERS ALIKE. WE DO, HOWEVER,
CONTINUE TO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO ADOPT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RELATING TO THE STATE
PARTICIPATION CAP FOR LOCAL
NEGOTIATIONS IN IHSS OR IN SAN
DIEGO AND RIVERSIDE. WITHOUT
THIS LANGUAGE, HOME CARE
PROVIDERS IN THESE COUNTIES, LOW
INCOME WOMEN OF COLOR WILL
ESSENTIALLY RECEIVE A PAY CUT IN
2025, AND THAT WILL BE
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING FOR OUR
WORKERS. SO WE APPRECIATE THE
ACTIONS TO COME TODAY AND
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, RONALD COLEMAN BASA
HERE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PANASONIC HEALTH NETWORK C-PEN.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
REJECTION OF THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE IN-HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES TO THE UNDOCUMENTED. A
PROPOSAL LIKE THAT SHOULD HAVE
NO PLACE IN THE DEBATE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WE APPRECIATE
NOT HAVING A DISCRIMINATORY
PROPOSAL CODIFIED IN STATE LAW.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE REJECTION
OF THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING, AND ALSO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM. WE ALSO APPRECIATE THAT
THERE MAY BE MODEST ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE MCO TAX, AND HOPE THAT
THERE CAN BE CONSIDERATION OF
RAISING REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
CHW COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS,
PROMOTERS AND HEALTH
REPRESENTATIVES, WHICH WOULD BE
A SMALL, VERY TINY PERCENTAGE OF
ANY FUNDING WITH THAT REVENUE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING YASMIN PILOT, ON BEHALF
OF JUSTICE AND AGING, THANK YOU
FOR REJECTING MANY OF THE
HARMFUL CUTS TO HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS FROM THE MAY
REVISION THAT WOULD IMPACT OLDER
ADULTS. SPECIFICALLY, I WANT TO
THANK THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE IHSS BENEFITS FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS AND
MAINTAINING THE IHSS BACKUP
PROVIDER SYSTEM. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE REJECTIONS OF THE
CUTS TO APS HOME SAFE, CALFRESH
AND SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAINTAIN THESE PROGRAMS IN THE
FINAL BUDGET DEAL WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND FINALLY, AS
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS
MODIFICATIONS TO THE MCO TAX, WE
ENCOURAGE TIMELY IMPLEMENTATION
OF SHERIFF COST REFORM, WHICH
CURRENTLY LEAVES OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
TRAPPED IN POVERTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. JESSICA
MORAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE GREATLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE LEGISLATURE
FOR REJECTING BOTH THE
ELIMINATION AND THE DELAY IN
FUNDING FOR THE SPECIALTY CLINIC
GRANT PROGRAM, REALLY HOPING TO
SEE THIS REFLECTED IN THE FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT ON THE OFFICE
OF RURAL HEALTH FUNDING. TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT CUTS NEED TO BE
MADE IN DIFFICULT BUDGET YEARS.
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
RESTORING THE CONTINUOUS FUNDING
AND FUTURE BUDGET YEARS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
BRANDON MARTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME AND THE
EFFORT THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PUT TO, THE
MCO PROPOSAL. AS YOU KNOW,
BILLIONS WENT TO THE MEDI-CAL
PROVIDER AND INCREASED MEDI-CAL
PROVIDER RATES, AND ALSO
BILLIONS MORE WENT TO THE
GENERAL FUND IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
BUDGET DEFICITS SUCH AS THIS
ONE, WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND ARE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT MONEY GOES OUT ON TIME. AND
AS WAS AGREED TO, IN 2025
INSTEAD OF 2026. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MOLLY
ROBSON WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL. REJECTS
ELIMINATION OF INVESTMENTS IN
MEDI-CAL, HOWEVER, THESE
INVESTMENTS CANNOT BE DELAYED TO
2026. WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
RESTORE THE TARGETED RATE
INCREASES. ORIGINALLY PROPOSED
TO BEGIN IN 2025, TO START IN
2025, TO PROTECT FUNDING FOR
FAMILY PLANNING AND ABORTION
SERVICES AND MAKE AN IMPACT IN
THE MEDI-CAL SYSTEM. BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MOLLY GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TAISHA WATTS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS. WE ARE SUPER
APPRECIATIVE OF THE RESTORATION
OF THE 74.1 MILLION TO THE SONG
BROWN RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. THIS
FUNDING WAS CRUCIAL IN ORDER FOR
US TO BUILD UP OUR PRIMARY CARE
WORKFORCE. WE ASKED ALSO THAT AS
BUDGET DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE,
WE KNOW THAT IT'S A TOUGH BUDGET
DECISION. BUT THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM IS CONSISTENTLY ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE STABLE FUNDING
SOURCE. SO WE ASK THAT THIS
FUNDING BE PRESERVED SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD UP OUR
PRIMARY CARE WORKFORCE AND
PROVIDE CARE TO THOSE RURAL AND
AREAS. AND I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
FROM CMA AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD
REGARDING THE PROVIDER RATES FOR
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS, PRIVATE
PROVIDER RATES FOR THE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS IN THE MCO, TAX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI. GOOD
MORNING, JASON SULLIVAN HALPERN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LONG-TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S 35 LOCAL LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS, WE
SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOU,
INCLUDING OUR PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS FROM TWO SPECIAL FUNDS
CONTROLLED BY CDF. THE NEED FOR
THIS FUNDING WAS INCREDIBLY
URGENT, AND WE THINK THIS IS
GOING TO PROVIDE THOSE PROGRAMS
WITH THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
KEEP OLDER ADULTS AND ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES LIVING IN LONG
TERM CARE SAFE, HAPPY AND
HEALTHY OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
AND WE CAN WORK ON A MORE LONG
TERM, PERMANENT SOLUTION THAT
DOESN'T REQUIRE COBBLING
TOGETHER SPECIAL FUNDS FROM
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. AND WE JUST
ARE TREMENDOUSLY GRATEFUL. AND
ALSO FOR YOUR REJECTION OF THE
CUTS FOR OUR PARTNERS AT APS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS.
SUSANNA MEYER, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR EMPOWERED AGING,
OFFERING OMBUDSMAN SERVICES FOR
ALAMEDA, CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO
COUNTIES. WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR REJECTION OF THE
MAY REVISE FOR THE CRITICAL
SAFETY NET SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
ARE KEEPING SENIORS IN THEIR
HOME LONGER. IF WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT THERE'S A CRISIS MODE IN
DIRECT CARE WORKFORCE, THERE'S A
HUGE AMOUNT OF GROWTH IN SENIOR
HOMELESSNESS. AND OF COURSE, THE
SENIOR POPULATION IS EXPANDING
RAPIDLY. SO WHATEVER WE CAN DO
TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES
LONGER WILL KEEP THEM SAFE AND
PROTECTED. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PROTECTION. THANKS HI. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, BETH
MALINOWSKI WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA
VÀ AS A PROUD PARTNER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT COALITION,
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
REJECTING THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO CUT 300 MILLION FROM
THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING. ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INVESTMENTS
IN PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE AND YOUR
RESTORATION OF CUTS TO THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
LIFTING UP HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
MORE BROADLY. THROUGH YOUR
COMMITMENT TO FUND THE HEALTH
CARE MINIMUM WAGE. LASTLY, WITH
OUR LABOR PARTNERS WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
STRIKING WORKERS AND HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE FOR THEM THROUGH
COVERED CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BUENOS DIAS, MADAM
CHAIR, AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
JUST MARIA ROMO, ON BEHALF OF
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER. JUST
WANT TO EXTEND GRATITUDE FOR,
REJECTING AND MODIFYING THE CUTS
TO CALWORKS THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM, EMERGENCY CHILD CARE,
FOSTER BRIDGE PROGRAM, AND ALSO
FOR RESTORING CHILD CARE SLOTS
FOR ALL OF OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
CHILDREN, AS THESE PROPOSALS
MAKE THEIR WAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK, WE STRONGLY ASK YOU TO
PLEASE PROTECT THEM AND KEEP
THEM IN MIND AS THEY'RE COMING
ACROSS HIS DESK, THE
ADMINISTRATION CANNOT AFFORD TO
CUT THESE PROGRAMS AND REDUCE
FUNDING LONGTERM AS IT IMPACTS
THE MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND FAMILIES IN OUR IN OUR
DISTRICTS, WE JUST WANT YOU TO
KEEP THEM IN MIND AND KNOW THAT
YOU ARE AFFECTING A LOT OF
FAMILIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DOESN'T DO THE THING FOR YOU.
GOOD MORNING, NICO, WITH THE
MESA VERDE GROUP HERE ON BEHALF
OF IMMIGRANT LEGAL DEFENSE AND
THE LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE CLINIC, WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED CUTS TO IMMIGRATION,
LEGAL SERVICES FOR THE CSU AND
TPS RECIPIENTS AND FUNDING THEM.
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET. THANK
YOU. THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON,
BARRY JARDINI, CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES ASSOCIATION
I WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR AGREEING TO A PROPOSAL. I
THINK THAT REFLECTS THE NEEDS OF
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
EVERYWHERE, PARTICULARLY THE
REJECTION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO DELAY THE RATE MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES, IT'S
A MASSIVE WIN OAN FOR TODAY,
AND WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
HOLD STRONG IN THE FINAL BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS. JUST A FINAL NOTE.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WATCH WORK THIS
YEAR. IT'S VERY TOUGH YEAR AND
YOU'VE DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, IN
BEING CONSIDERATE AND THOUGHTFUL
IN IN LIGHT OF VERY DIFFICULT
NEWS. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING, MEMBER
AND CHAIRS, LYDIA MICHAILIDIS.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
ADULT DAY SERVICES. I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR HOPES, DREAMS AND
PRAYERS ON BEHALF OF THE ALMOST
40,000 PARTICIPANTS SERVED BY
OUR AMAZING, ALMOST 300
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
PROGRAMS WHO ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH INFLATIONARY
COSTS THAT HAVE, NOT ONLY GONE
UP BUT ARE IN ADDITION TO
RECOVERING FROM THE PANDEMIC
STILL. AND I KNOW YOU PERSONALLY
SAW WITH YOUR OWN EYES, SENATOR
MANYAVAR, WHAT THAT IMPACT HAS
ON PEOPLE'S LIVES, WHEN THEY CAN
RECEIVE THESE SERVICES SO THAT
WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
KEEP SEA BASS IN THE MIX AS YOU
PURSUE YOUR FINAL CLOSING DAYS
OF THESE NEGOTIATIONS. AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THUS FAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, AND
THE MEMBERS. SO WE JUST GOT FROM
LOS ANGELES TO HERE. SO WE COME
HERE TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
MEDICARE, MEDI-CAL, ACUPUNCTURE
CUT. MEDICARE HAS BEEN PAYING
ACUPUNCTURE WITH VERY MINIMAL
BUDGET, AND THE COVER FOR ABOUT
MILLION OF MEDICAL
BENEFICIARIES. SO THE COST IS
MINIMAL. BUT THE BENEFIT IS
HUGE. IF CUT THE MEDI-CAL
ACUPUNCTURE BENEFIT, THOSE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
ACUPUNCTURE. ACUPUNCTURE HAS
BEEN PROVED TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE
FOR PAIN MANAGEMENT AND THE ANTI
OPIOID CRISIS. AND I HOPE WE
WILL KEEP AS LOS ANGELES. WE
KNOW A LOT OF MOVIE STARS. THEY
SAU ADORE ACUPUNCTURE AND
DEPOSED ON TV SOCIAL MEDIA. AND
MEANWHILE A LOS ANGELES HAS A
LOT OF MEDICAL PATIENTS AND THEY
CANNOT SO JUST NEIGHBORHOOD.
SOMEBODY CAN ACCESS ACUPUNCTURE
AND SOME OTHER PEOPLE JUST DON'T
HAVE ACCESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND WE REJECTED THAT PROPOSAL.
IF YOU DON'T. OKAY, MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS, I'D JUST LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MY REMARKS WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER, ACUPUNCTURE
UNDER MEDI-CAL GIVES OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND OUR
MOST UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
ACCESS TO THIS IMPORTANT
MEDICINE, WHICH IS BOTH
EFFECTIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE.
NON-OPIOID AND
NON-PHARMACEUTICAL. AND WE
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR WORK
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND HOPE
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO STAY STRONG
AND WORKING TO MAINTAIN FULL
FUNDING FOR ACUPUNCTURE UNDER
MEDI-CAL FOR THESE KEY
POPULATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, DENNIS CUEVAS
ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION
ADVOCATES, APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND A TOUGH BUDGET
YEAR. I WANTED TO SPEAK BRIEFLY
ON THE MCO TAX. APPRECIATE THE
APPROACH BY THE LEGISLATURE FOR
HEALTH CENTERS. AS YOU KNOW, YOU
TARGETED RATE INCREASES AREN'T
GOING TO BE REACHING THE HEALTH
CENTERS. HOWEVER, SPECIALTY CARE
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO REFER OUR PATIENTS. SO
WE WOULD URGE THE, THE TARGETED
RATE INCREASES TO BE MOVED TO
THIS BUDGET YEAR. ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S, REJECTION OF THE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS, SPECIFICALLY
THE HEALTH ENROLLMENT NAVIGATOR
FOR CLINICS PROGRAM, THE
OPTIONAL MEDI-CAL, CUT FOR
ACUPUNCTURE, THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM, AND VARIOUS HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS, PARTICULARLY
SONG BROWN, THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICINE SCHOLARS PROGRAM, AND
THE HEALTH CAREER OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM. SO REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL. THANK YOU. WORK. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR, TONY ANDERSON,
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP, TO FROM YOU AND THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE, THIS IS,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU
ABOUT THE IMPACT AND THE NEED IN
OUR COMMUNITY, AND YOU CLEARLY
LISTENED. A LOT OF PEOPLE COME
TO ME AND SAY, WHY SHOULD I TELL
MY LEGISLATORS THIS? THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO LISTEN TO ME. YOU ALL
CLEARLY LISTEN TO THE WHAT WOULD
THE IMPACT OF THE DELAY IN THE
RATE REFORM BE? AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO CONTINUE THAT FIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
PHILIP YANG FROM CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITY, SILICON VALLEY, I AM
REPRESENTING ALL THE SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ACUPUNCTURE TO
THANK YOU, ALL THE SENATE
MEMBERS, FOR YOUR EFFORTS FOR
THE REJECTION OF THE REDUCTION
AND ELIMINATION FOR ACUPUNCTURE
BUDGET IN THE, MEDICAL PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS. I COME FROM UKIAH,
MENDOCINO COUNTY. I'M AN
ACUPUNCTURIST. I DO A LOT OF,
FREE TREATMENT FOR THE
COMMUNITIES, EVEN THE TEMPLE WHO
PEOPLE THEY ARE REALLY NEED
MEDI-CAL, MEDI-CAL AND TO
RELEASE THE PAIN. WHICH I DOING
MORE 20 YEARS THEN I KNOW
ACUPUNCTURE CAN HELP A LOT OF
PEOPLE RELEASE THE PAIN. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW OR TO THANK
YOU YOU GUYS AND TO REJECT. BUT
EVEN IF THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
K¾T TO OPEN THIS CASE TO
CONSIDER ABOUT IT, WE ARE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, JORDAN. LINDSEY WITH
THE ARC OF CALIFORNIA, THE ARC
OF UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE LANTERMAN
COALITION, WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ACROSS THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECTORS IN PROTECTING SERVICES
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
WHAT HAS COME OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE ACTIONS THAT
ARE ABOUT TO OCCUR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
LINDA WEI WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY. I WANT TO ECHO
ALL OUR APPRECIATION FOR
PRESERVING CRITICAL SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. SPECIFICALLY, WE
APPRECIATE PRESERVING THE
CRITICAL CALWORKS PROGRAMS AND
THE AUTHORITY TO APPLY FOR THE
FEDERAL PILOT THAT ALLOWS US TO
IMPLEMENT SOME FAMILY CENTERED
CHANGES, AS WELL AS APPRECIATE,
FOSTER CARE PROGRAMS, NUTRITION
BENEFITS, AS WELL AS THE SAFETY
NET BEING PRESERVED. I'D ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR STOPPING, DISCRIMINATORY,
DISCRIMINATORY CUTS TO THE IHSS
PROGRAM, AND FINALLY, AS THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS
MODIFICATIONS TO THE MCO TAX,
WOULD URGE TIMELY IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE SHERIFF COST REFORM SO
THAT SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES CAN ACCESS
MEDI-CAL, THANK YOU. AND WE
STAND READY BEHIND YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO, MARION. YOU KNOW,
CHILD CARE LAW CENTER, WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO RELEASE THE
SPACES AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. AND
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO PUT
THE 200,000 SPACE EXPANSION IN
TRAIL BUILDING. WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE CHILD CARE REVERSION
ACCOUNT. UNTIL CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS HAVE A FAIR PAY, WE
WILL NOT HAVE AN EQUITABLE
SOCIETY. WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
FOR PLACEHOLDER TRAIL BILL
LANGUAGE THAT INCLUDES REPORTING
DEADLINES AND PROTECTIVE
POLICIES FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF RATE REFORM, PAYING PROVIDERS
BASED ON THE FULL COST OF
ENRICHING CURES IS A CRITICAL
STEP TO WRITING HISTORICAL
WRONGS. WE THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR MINIMIZING CUTS TO CALWORKS,
BUT WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CUT ALL THE TO REJECT ALL THE
CUTS THE CAR WORKS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS KATHY
MCDONALD FOR THE COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA HERE TO EXPRESS THANKS
AND SUPPORT FOR THE RESTORATIONS
AND REDUCTIONS TO CUTS OF THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING.
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT AND
RELATED FUNDING HOUSING PROGRAMS
SUCH AS HAP BRINGING FAMILIES
HOME AND HOME SAFE, AS WELL AS
THE REDUCTIONS TO THE SWEEPING
AND REALLY DEVASTATING CUTS
PROPOSED TO NUMEROUS COUNTY
ADMINISTERED HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS SERVING CHILDREN,
ADULTS AND FAMILIES, INCLUDING
THOSE WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. WE REMAIN
READY TO HELP AND ASSIST IN ANY
WAY AS THE PROCESS MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TIFFANY WHEATON WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA JUST REALLY WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
PROTECT OUR FAMILIES, OUR
CHILDREN, OUR AGING, AND OUR
FOSTER YOUTH BY REJECTING THE
PROPOSALS TO CALWORKS IN
PARTICULAR, FAMILY
STABILIZATION, CHILD WELFARE,
SPECIFICALLY FORS ALSO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT TO THE
PILOT AND CONTINUED DISCUSSION
THERE. THE REJECTION TO IHSS
APS, THE DELAY TO THE DD RATE
STUDY AND FOR IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES AND APPRECIATE
MAINTAINING FUNDS IN THE SAFETY
NET RESERVES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS TIM
MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS. WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ACTION TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AS RELATES TO THE MCO TAX,
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE 2425 YEAR
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN. WE
WOULD ASK THAT YOU KEEP IN MIND
THE EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS, AS
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THOSE AND
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS,
UNFORTUNATELY, WITH ALL THE
OTHER CUTS THAT MAY HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD, WE'RE ANTICIPATING A
HEAVY FLOW OF MEDI-CAL PATIENTS
COMING INTO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. SO WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD TIME TO BUTTRESS AND
SUPPORT THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE. AND THEN
QUICKLY, I ALSO REPRESENT THE
GROSSMONT HEALTHCARE DISTRICT,
AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT
ESTABLISHING A NEW SONG, BROWN
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAM.
SO WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
RESTORING SOME OF THOSE MONIES,
IT'S A LITTLE BIT UNCLEAR ON HOW
IT RELATES TO NEW PROGRAMS. I
KNOW THE INTENT WAS TO REALLY
FOCUS ON THOSE EXISTING
PROGRAMS, WHICH WE COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE. BUT JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT FOR YOU ALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
JACKIE GONZALEZ, POLICY DIRECTOR
AT IMMIGRANT DEFENSE ADVOCATES.
IT'S NICE TO BE HERE AND FEEL
HAPPY. THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
AND THE STAFF, I THINK TODAY WE
FEEL LIKE THE VOICES OF THE
PEOPLE THAT CAME TO SACRAMENTO
WERE HEARD. AND WE'RE DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE REJECTION OF
THE CUTS TO IHSS, CSU AND TPS,
WE UNDERSTAND IT'S A DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEAR. WE WERE SADDENED TO
NOT SEE, CHIRP INCLUDED THE
CHILDREN'S HOLISTIC IMMIGRATION
REPRESENTATION PROJECT, BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR WAYS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN, HAVE
HAVE A SAFETY NET HERE. THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANKS GOOD MORNING.
HAMID YAZDAN, ON BEHALF OF LUMA
ACTION, ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE. THANK YOU FOR
PROTECTING IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES, THE TPS AND THE CSU
PROGRAM, AND ALSO EMPHASIZING A
NEED TO FIND A REPLACEMENT FOR
THE CHIRP PROGRAM FOR
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR CHILDREN
THAT PROGRAMS FUNDING IS NOT
BEING RENEWED, BUT THE ISSUE
REMAINS. THESE CHILDREN NEED
SUPPORT SERVICES. THEY NEED
LEGAL SERVICES AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS SARA
FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION I'M GOING TO ECHO ONE
OF THE PRIOR SPEAKERS. IT'S GOOD
TO BE HERE AND FEEL HAPPY AND
HOPEFUL. AND THAT IS BECAUSE OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP. AND WE THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR ALL OF
THE WORK YOU'VE DONE. WE'RE
PARTICULARLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL LANGUAGE FOR
HEALTH CARE, FOR STRIKING
WORKERS TO CONTINUE, AND GIVE
THAT PROGRAM STABILITY. WE ALSO
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
ACTIONS TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
BY REJECTING THE CUTS TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAM, AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
RESTORATION, BUT VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE CHILD CARE SLOTS AS WELL.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD
WORK. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. NICK
BROKAW FROM SACRAMENTO ADVOCATES
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF AUDIOLOGY. I HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR
YOUR EFFORTS TO PUSH FOR THE
RESTORATION OF FUNDING FOR
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
AUDIOLOGY. AND WE JUST NOTE THAT
IN ADDITION TO THE IMPACT THIS
HAS ON DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
INDIVIDUALS, CERTAINLY THIS
COMMITTEE'S FOCUS ON THE HEARING
AID COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
PROGRAM REALLY CRITICAL JUST TO,
RECOGNIZE THAT THE RATES FOR
AUDIOLOGIST S MEDI-CAL SPACE IS
INEXTRICABLY LINKED TO THE RATES
THAT ARE PROVIDED FOR SERVICES
FOR THE HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, JAMIE
MINER, ON BEHALF OF VERTEX
PHARMACEUTICALS. WANT TO ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
SICKLE CELL DISEASE FOUNDATION?
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE $5
MILLION FOR THE SICKLE CELL
DISEASE CLINICS. WE THINK IT
WILL SAVE THE STATE OVER $100
MILLION A YEAR DUE TO REDUCED
HOSPITALIZATION AND TIME WITHIN
HOSPITALS. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. HI, MADAM CHAIR, AND
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MARK DEAL
AND I'M THE CEO OF CALIFORNIA
COVERAGE AND HEALTH INITIATIVES
AND A MEMBER OF THE MEDI-CAL FOR
OLDER ADULTS COALITION. I'M HERE
TO ASK AGAIN FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR THAT PROGRAM FOR THE
FUNDING RENEWAL REAUTHORIZATION,
THÀNH, AND SUPPORT FOR THE
REQUEST SUBMITTED BY SENATOR
DODD. THAT PROGRAM HELPS UP TO
1.6 MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
IN NEED OF HEALTH CARE,
NAVIGATION SERVICES. IN SOME
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY LIVE,
THEY HAVE ABOUT 165 DIFFERENT
MEDI-CAL AND MEDICARE OPTIONS TO
CHOOSE FROM. AND OUR FOLKS THAT
WORK AT CBOS COUNTIES COMMUNITY
CLINICS HELP THEM NAVIGATE INTO
THE BEST PROGRAM TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS. THIS PROGRAM DRAWS DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS AND PROVIDES A LOT
OF JOBS IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE, AND SERVES THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY WITH
AFSCME CALIFORNIA, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR REMARKABLE WORK,
ALONG WITH COMMITTEE STAFF ON
ATTEMPTING TO CRAFT A PROPOSAL
THAT REALLY TRIES TO MITIGATE
THE SEVERE CUTS TO CORE SERVICES
AND PROGRAMS THAT MANY FOLKS IN
THE STATE RELY ON. JUST WANT TO
UPLIFT THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE BY OUR AFSCME AFFILIATE,
UAW LOCAL 3930, AND ALSO, MANY
OF OUR LABOR PARTNERS WHO CAME
AND SPOKE BEFORE ME, ALSO WANT
TO UPLIFT THE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR PROTECTING THE 3000, $300
MILLION, FOR PUBLIC HEALTH, AND
WANT TO ALSO EMPHASIZE JUST
REALLY THANK YOU FOR RESPECTING
THE NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT ON THE
MCO TAX. IN PARTICULAR, WE WERE
FOCUSED ON THE $50 MILLION FOR
GROUND EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION,
WHERE THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AREN'T AS ON PAR WITH PUBLIC
EMERGENCY SERVICES. SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND, AS THESE
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE TO MOVE
ON IN NEGOTIATIONS, LET US KNOW
HOW WE CAN HELP PRESERVE, THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, MARK FAROOQ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE THE OUTYEAR
RESTORATION OF THE MCO TAX
FUNDING UNDER THE EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
STATE BUDGET. HOWEVER, WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE LACK OF
FUNDING IN THE CURRENT BUDGET
YEAR FOR RATE INCREASES TO
PROTECT AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE FOR MEDI-CAL
PATIENTS. AS YOU KNOW, MANY
HOSPITALS REMAIN IN SEVERE
FINANCIAL DISTRESS FROM THE
COVID 19 PANDEMIC AND RISING
MEDICAL INFLATION FOR
PHARMACEUTICALS, AS WELL AS
MEDICAL SUPPLIES, SO APPRECIATE
YOUR CONTINUED CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. THANKS, MARK. GOOD
MORNING. I'M JEAN HIÂU FOR
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF CHINESE
MEDICINE AND ACUPUNCTURE, YEAH.
SO PLEASE KEEP ACUPUNCTURE
SERVICE IN MEDI-CAL BECAUSE IT
IS EFFECTIVE IN THE SAFE AND THE
LOW COST TREATMENT. PLEASE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS CHEN ZHAO SHA. I HAVE A
PRACTICE, CLINIC. ACUPUNCTURE
CLINIC IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO. I
ONLY WANT TO KNOW. WANT TO SAY
IF YOU CUT THE MEDICARE BUDGET
FOR THE PATIENT. FOR SURE. THEN
IT'S UNNECESSARY, EMERGENCY
SERVICE AND SURGERY WILL COST
MORE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING. HI. MORNING, I
AM WEN ZHANG FROM AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF CHINESE MEDICINE
AND ACUPUNCTURE, I'M HERE TO
VOICE FOR KEEPING ACUPUNCTURE IN
THE MEDICAL SYSTEM, BUT I JUST
HEARD A GREAT NEWS. YOU TURNED
DOWN THE PROPOSAL, SO I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO YOU KEEPING THE
ACUPUNCTURE IN THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ
WITH THE CRLA GROUP HERE ON
BEHALF OF CARESS AND THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER AND
INCLUSIVE ACTION FOR THE CITY,
ECHOING THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES,
INCLUDING THE CHIRP PROGRAM, AND
ALSO THE COMMENTS RELATED TO
UNDOCUMENTED AND, CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE RECEIVING IHSS. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, KELLY LARUE WITH
RESILIENT ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
P-H-I AIR AMBULANCE AND THE AIR
AMBULANCE INDUSTRY, WE
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE RESTORING THE MCO TAX
AND ARE HOPEFUL TO BE CONSIDERED
AS PART OF THE ADDITIONAL RATE
INCREASES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL PRIORITIZE, AS THE SPECIAL
FUND TO FUND THE SUPPLEMENTAL
AIR AMBULANCE PAYMENT FOR
MEDI-CAL MEMBERS. IS NO LONGER
THERE'S NO MONEY IN THERE
ANYMORE. AND THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE IS ABOUT 20% OF THE COST OF
A TRANSPORT FEE SERVES THE RURAL
NORTH. SO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE,
THIS IS A REALLY CHALLENGING
SITUATION FOR US. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THE CHAIR. I
HAVE A LITTLE SIGN HERE THAT
SAYS I LIKE ACUPUNCTURE AND I
VOTE, I'M A DOCTOR OF
ACUPUNCTURE, I'M A TEACHER, AND
I'VE BEEN A MEDI-CAL PROVIDER
FOR MY PATIENTS SINCE 1988 AT A
REIMBURSEMENT OF $16 AT THE
TIME, I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT PAIN AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS FOR OPIOIDS, BUT
WE ARE PRIMARY CARE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, AND WE HAVE
FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN TO
THANK FOR THAT. AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE GAVIN NEWSOM
TO KEEP WITH HIS, UNDERSTANDING
OF PROVIDING MEDICAL CARE FOR
THE UNDOCUMENTED, THE
UNDERSERVED, THE SENIORS, OF
WHICH I'M ONE, AND THAT HE HAS
PROMISED IN HIS EARLIER
CAMPAIGNS TO DO THAT AND TO
FOLLOW THE LEGACY OF FORMER
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN, WHO
CREATED THE ACUPUNCTURE LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA, AND THAT WE TREAT
MORE THAN PAIN. WE WORK WITH
INFERTILITY. THANK YOU.
EVERYTHING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
CINDY VISALO AND I'M A STUDENT
OF TRADITIONAL CHINESE MEDICINE.
AT FIVE BRANCHES UNIVERSITY IN
SANTA CRUZ. ON BEHALF OF OUR
PATIENTS AND OUR STUDENTS
BECOMING FUTURE ACUPUNCTURISTS,
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE FOR PROTECTING AND
RESTORING ACUPUNCTURE BENEFITS
FOR OUR MEDI-CAL PATIENTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR HARD WORK.
GOOD MORNING, HENRY COHEN. ALSO
A STUDENT AT FIVE BRANCHES
UNIVERSITY IN SANTA CRUZ AND
ASPIRING ACUPUNCTURIST. I JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR RESTORING AND REJECTING THE
PROPOSED CUTS TO ACUPUNCTURE.
AND AS SOMEBODY WHO ASPIRES TO
GO INTO ACUPUNCTURE AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVANT USING MEDI-CAL,
I'M JUST VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
PRESERVATION YOU GUYS ARE
PROVIDING. AND JUST WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES ON THE MARGINS,
WATCHING PEOPLE GET OFF OF
OPIATES USING ACUPUNCTURE IS
VERY POWERFUL EXPERIENCE.
PERSONALLY FOR ME, AND I'M SURE
AS MANY PEOPLE HAVE EXPERIENCED
HERE, SO JUST WANT TO REMIND
EVERYONE THAT ACUPUNCTURE DOES
WORK. AND THANK YOU FOR VALUING
IT. THANK YOU. MORNING, JOHN
DREBINGER WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE, WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO
PRESERVE CRITICAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FUNDING AND JUST EXPRESS
WE REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CUTS TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE FUNDING. OUR ESTIMATES
INDICATE THAT WE NEED 375,000
NEW BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
TO COME ONLINE OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS. AND
THOSE DOLLARS OFTEN TAKE YEARS
TO SEE AN IMPACT ON THE ACTUAL
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE PROVIDERS
IN THE WORKFORCE. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED ATTENTION TO
THE ISSUE. THANK YOU. HI. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM. CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS. DE WU WITH NORTHEAST
MEDICAL SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF
LEGISLATURA RESTORATIONS OF
ACUPUNCTURE SURFACES IN MEDI-CAL
AND PLEASE CONTINUE THIS SUPPORT
IN THE BUDGET FOR FUTURE YEARS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS VIVIAN LIANG WITH
NORTHEAST MEDICAL SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
RESTORATION OF ACUPUNCTURE
SERVICES IN MEDI-CAL. I ALSO
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
REJECTION OF CUTS TO BROWN
INDIAN HEALTH MEDICINE SCHOLARS
HEALTH ENROLLMENT FOR NAVIGATORS
FOR CLINICS, AND JUST OTHER ESTÁ
HØI. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NOW
MAKE SURE TO TELL THE
ADMINISTRATION, OKAY. HI SOUMYA
NHÀ ON BEHALF OF BREAST CARE
COMMUNITY LIVING, WE JUST WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR THANKS FOR
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO DELAY THE PROVIDER
RATE REFORM, BUT ALSO WANTED TO
EXPRESS THAT WE REMAIN
SIGNIFICANTLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE THREE CATEGORIES OF
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
THAT HAVE NOT RECEIVED AN
ADJUSTMENT SINCE 2022, AND AS A
100% MEDI-CAL PROVIDER, IT IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
MEET ALL THE COSTS TO EMPLOY
PROVIDERS WITHOUT THE 1.5%
ADJUSTMENT. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS OF PAMELA GIBBS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. IT'S
A PLEASURE TO SEE THE WORK THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN DOING
BRIEFLY, JUST TWO ITEMS TODAY.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PROPOSALS TO
REJECT CUTS TO CHILD CARE AND
THE RESTORATION OF FUNDING FOR
CALWORKS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE COMING
DAYS AND WEEKS, ON CONCLUDING
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND WE'LL
FOLLOW UP WITH THE LETTER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD LUCK WITH
THE PROCESS IN THE NEXT COMING
WEEKS. THANK YOU. HELLO, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, KATTY BERG
WITH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA,
THANKING YOU FOR KEEPING THE
FUTURE OF PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING
IN YOUR VERSION OF THE BUDGET,
AS YOU KNOW, THIS FUNDS NOT JUST
PREPAREDNESS FOR FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH ACTIVITIES, BUT FOR WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE ON THE GROUND
RIGHT NOW. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE WILL BE TELLING THE
ADMINISTRATION, THANK YOU.
THANKS HELLO. MY NAME IS ELBA
GONZALEZ MÁS. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
INITIATIVE. I'M HERE AS A MEMBER
OF THE OLDER ADULT COALITION
HERE, RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING
THE CONTINUATION OF SUCH A VITAL
PROGRAM THAT HELPS OLDER ADULTS
NAVIGATE REALLY COMPLEX PUBLIC
PROGRAMS. ONE OF THOSE, OF
COURSE, BEING MEDI-CAL. IN MY 20
YEARS OF DOING THIS WORK, THIS
IS THE ONLY SPACE WHERE I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO REALLY MEANINGFUL
ADDRESS AND HELPING SENIORS
ACCESS SERVICES BY, OF COURSE, A
WAY OF HAVING INSURANCE, BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY, BEING ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO MEET THEIR NEEDS AT
SUCH A CRITICAL STAGE OF THEIR
LIVES AND HAVING THAT BE DONE
WITH A WHOLE FULL COALITION. SO
WE DO RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO THAT VERY IMPORTANT
WORK FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE,
AGED, BLIND AND DISABLED IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. HI, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, BRANDON TATE
WITH THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
EQUITY COALITION. I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS AND THE STAFF
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE HARD
WORK THAT WENT INTO THIS. THANK
YOU FOR THE REJECTION OF THE
CUTS TO THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY, PARTICULARLY THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CHANGE PROGRAM, AS
WELL AS THE FUTURE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAM. THESE ARE REALLY
ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS TO OUR YOUTH
IN THE STATE. INVESTING IN OUR
FUTURE, PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
LGBTQ YOUTH WHO ARE THE MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU. AND IF
THERE'S ANYTHING OUR COALITION
CAN DO AS YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THIS, PLEASE LET US
KNOW. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR MEMBERS TRENT MURPHY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES. FIRST OFF, WE WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE ON THE
REVERSAL OF THE PROPOSAL ON THE
MCO TAX AND REINSTATING THOSE
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES. ALSO
THE REDUCTION OR THE CHANGE FROM
THE ELIMINATION OF THE CALWORKS
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
FROM AN ELIMINATION TO A
REDUCTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT MODEST PROPOSAL, ALSO
WANT TO, RESTATE THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE. WE'RE A PART OF THEIR
COALITION ON THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE REDUCTION AND
WANT TO BRING THAT UP IN THE
COMING TALKS AND APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR WORK IN THIS COMMITTEE, AND
THANK YOU FOR THE CHANGE TO
REDUCTIONS FROM ELIMINATIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR, MEMBERS, RANDY MARTIN, ON
BEHALF OF AVIANO HEALTHCARE,
AFTER WEEKS AND WEEKS OF ASKING,
ASKING, ASKING, I'M HERE TODAY
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR VERY
PROFOUND COMMITMENT TO PRIVATE
DUTY NURSING, AS WELL AS YOUR
PROTECTION OF THE RATE REFORM
FOR DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION, I APPRECIATE YOUR
REJECTING THE $300 MILLION IN
PUBLIC HEALTH CUTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THOSE WHO CAME FOR THE
FINAL PUBLIC COMMENT, OF SUB
THREE OF THIS YEAR, BEFORE WE GO
INTO OUR VOTES, LET'S ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM, IF WE CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS MENGIBAR
HERE. MENGIBAR HERE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN! HERE. GROVE. GROVE, HERE
. ROTH. ROTH. HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU. QUORUM IS
PRESENT. THIS PAST TWO YEARS
HAVE BEEN. SO EDUCATIONAL,
FRUSTRATING, EMOTIONAL, A LOT OF
HEARTBURN AND SO FORTH, BUT NO
WHITE OR GRAY HAIRS CAME OUT, SO
I AM THANKFUL FOR THAT, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT NEXT YEAR WILL BRING.
I'VE BEEN SO HONORED AND BLESSED
TO BE ON THIS SUB, THREE COMM
COMMITTEE, I WANT TO THANK MY
FIRST, MY TWO COLLEAGUES TO THE
RIGHT WHO ARE LEAVING US AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HOLDING DOWN THE FORT
WITH ME, AND I IT'S BEEN AN
HONOR TO WORK ALONGSIDE YOU.
THESE ARE TWO OF MY FAVORITE
SENATORS IN THE SENATE THAT I'VE
LEARNED SO MUCH FROM, YOU KNOW,
SENATOR EGGMAN HAS BEEN IN THIS
SPACE FOR A LONG TIME. WILL
CONTINUE TO BE IN THIS SPACE
FOLLOWING HER TENURE HERE.
GENERAL ROTH IS A TRUE, MOST
WORTHY MAN WHO STANDS FIRM TO
HIS BELIEFS. AND I THINK WE SAW
A GOOD EXIT, FROM LAST WEEK'S
AND THE QUESTIONING HE PROVIDED.
IT WAS A GOOD WAY TO GO OUT,
SENATOR GROVE, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALSO BEING A HUGE CHAMPION
FOR OUR YOUTH. OUR FOSTER KIDS
AND SO FORTH FOR, DOUBLING DOWN
ON THE MANY QUESTIONS THAT I HAD
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
DEPARTMENTS WHO CAME IN. I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU, HONING IN
ON THAT AS WELL. IT'S BEEN A
GREAT HONOR TO THE ADVOCATES,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CONTINUING
TO BE LOUD IN ALL THESE ISSUES.
AS YOU HEARD, THE VOTES WERE
TAKEN TODAY. ARE BECAUSE OF
EVERYTHING THAT WE HEARD FROM
OUR ADVOCATES. THE ENDLESS
AMOUNT OF LOBBYING THAT CAME, I
WILL SAY SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE SOME OF THE THINGS I CHANGED
MY MIND ON BECAUSE I HEARD OF
THE IMPACT THAT IT WAS GOING TO
CAUSE, SO A LOT OF YOUR ADVOCACY
REALLY, REALLY, REALLY DOES
WORK. AND SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I'M HOPING THAT FROM THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS, YOU WILL
CONTINUE JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO ENSURE THAT WHAT WE PASS
TODAY IS AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE TO
WHAT WE GET IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF WEEKS, SO WITH THAT, I'D LIKE
TO GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ANY
MEMBERS. SENATOR ROTH. WELL,
MADAM CHAIR, JUST LET ME SAY
THIS WITH APOLOGIES TO YOUR
PREDECESSORS. BEST CHAIR. EVER,
EVER. THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR
ROTH. YEAH, AS ONE OF THOSE
FORMER NOT QUITE ADEQUATE
CHAIRS, I WOULD I WOULD I WOULD
CONCUR WITH THAT, YEAH. YOUR I
THINK YOUR YOUR CLARITY, YOUR
COURAGE, YOUR COMPASSION, AT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME, PROVIDED
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED. I
APPRECIATE AND ADMIRE YOUR
STRENGTH, YOUR COURAGE, AND
AGAIN, YOUR MORAL CLARITY WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES. IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO
WATCH YOU, YOU WORK, AS AS
LEAVING MEMBERS. WE SAT IN OR.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE LAO, A HUGE HELP
OF, FOR ME TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE CONTEXT FOR, FOR THINGS
AS WE GRAPPLED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS, MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON USED TO
BE MY FAVORITE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE, BUT HAVING BEEN ABLE
TO SERVE ON YOU AND SEE YOUR
PASSION, YOUR TENACITY, I AND
AGAIN, APOLOGIES TO THE
GOVERNOR, BUT SENATOR MENGIBAR
IS A FORCE TO BE RECKONED WITH.
AND SHE'S GOING TO DEFEND THIS
POPULATION, TO THE DEATH SHE IS.
AND SHE'S A MARINE CORPS
VETERAN. AND I DON'T MEAN THAT
LIKE, LITERALLY, BUT SHE'S GOING
TO FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE THAT SHE
SERVES. AND SO, MAYBE NEXT YEAR,
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT, YOU KNOW, CHALLENGING
THESE THINGS, AT FIRST AND
LOOKING AT OTHER MEASURES TO
MAKE CUTS AND NOTHING AGAINST
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING. I REALIZE WE'RE TRYING TO
BALANCE A BALANCE OF BUDGET, BUT
YOU DON'T START WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY,
AND YOU DEFINITELY DON'T START
WITH THE MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS
OF SOCIETY. WHEN YOU GOT A
MARINE CORPS VETERAN AS A CHAIR
THAT ADVOCATES WITH THEIR WHOLE
HEART, FOR THESE THESE ISSUES.
SO APPLAUD THE CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU,
SENATORS, I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SENTIMENTS. MY NORTH STAR
ARE TO MY LEFT AND TO MY RIGHT,
ELIZABETH AND SCOTT, IF YOU
HAVEN'T MET THEM, ARE JUST
BEYOND AMAZING, THEIR, THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF THIS IS THE REASON
WHY I'VE BEEN ABLE TO BE SO
PREPARED. BECAUSE THEY PREPARE
ME SO, SO WELL. THEY'RE SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT EVERYTHING
UNDER HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES,
BECAUSE WITHOUT REALLY
PASSIONATE STAFF, I DON'T THINK
WE COULD DO THE WORK THAT WE CAN
DO. SO I WANT TO THANK THEM SO
MUCH. FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS,
IT'S BEEN AMAZING TO WORK WITH
THEM ALONGSIDE THEM, SO WITH
THAT, WE'RE DOING THREE VOTES.
ON I'M GOING TO READ OFF EVERY
SINGLE ITEM AND THEN I'M GOING
TO NEED A MOTION AND THEN WE'LL
VOTE. SO WE'RE FIRST VOTING ON
GROUP A CONSENT ITEMS. ITEMS ONE
THROUGH THREE, TEN, 12 THROUGH
23, 25, 29, 31, 34 THROUGH 39,
43, 44, 46, 48, 49, 56 THROUGH
58, 61, 62, 65, 67 THROUGH 71,
74, 76, 77, 83, 85, THROUGH 87,
89, THROUGH 91, 94 THROUGH 98,
102, 104, 106, 108, ONE, TEN,
112, 115, 117, 119. THROUGH 122,
133 THROUGH 138, ONE 4142, 154,
158 THROUGH 167, 173 THROUGH
175, 177 THROUGH ONE 8182
THROUGH 186, 188 THROUGH 186,
189, 200, 202 THROUGH 205, 207
THROUGH 209, 215 THROUGH TWO, 18
TO 20 TO 23 THROUGH 229, 231,
233 THROUGH 238, 240 THROUGH
242, 244, 246 THROUGH 258, 260
THROUGH 264, 270 THROUGH 273 AND
276 THROUGH 279. I DIDN'T READ
ALL THESE, SO I CAN BE NUMBER
ONE AS WHO TALKS THE MOST
LEGISLATORS. I HAD TO READ ALL
THESE NUMBERS, I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION ON THOSE CONSENT ITEMS
MOVED BY SENATOR GROVE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
MENGIBAR. AYE. MENGIBAR. I
EGGMAN I EGGMAN I GROVE I GROVE
I ROTH A ROTH I ON A VOTE OF 4
TO 0, THOSE CONSENT ITEMS ARE
APPROVED. MOVING ON TO OUR GROUP
B OF VOTES, WE ARE NOW GOING TO
BE VOTING ON ITEMS SIX, SEVEN,
26, 27, 30, 40, 50, 52, 53, 64,
72, 81, 84, 92, 99, 105, 113,
116, 123 THROUGH 132, 156, 157,
168, 169, 172 2652 68 THROUGH
269. LOOKING FOR A MOTION SO
MOVED, SO MOVED BY. SENATOR
ROTH, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
EGGMAN I EGGMAN I. GROVE. GROVE
NÓ. ROTH. ROTH I. OUR FINAL VOTE
IS ON GROUP C! WE'RE GOING TO BE
VOTING ON ITEMS FOUR, FIVE,
EIGHT, NINE, 11, 24, 28, 32, 33,
41, 42, 45, 47, 51, 54, 55, 59,
60, 63, 66, 73, 75, 78, 80, 82,
88, 93, 100, 101, 103, 107, 109,
ONE, 11, ONE, 14, ONE, 18, ONE,
39, 141, 155, ONE 7171, 176,
181, 187, 197, 198, 2012062 TEN
THROUGH 214, 219, 221 THROUGH
222, TWO 3232 TO 39, 243, 245
259 266 THROUGH 267, 274 THROUGH
275, 280 THROUGH 281. LOOKING
FOR A MOTION. SO MOVED. MOVED BY
SENATOR ROTH, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GROVE. ROTH I ROTH I ON A VOTE
OF 3 TO 0, THAT GROUP SECTION
PASSES. THOSE ARE OUR FINAL
VOTES. YOUR TASK NOW IS TO
CONTINUE ADVOCACY TO ENSURE THAT
THE THREE PARTY DEAL STAYS AS
CLOSE AS POSSIBLE. TO THIS, MY
HAT'S OFF TO YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND HOPEFULLY WE SEE EACH
OTHER NEXT YEAR. BUT IT'S UP TO
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES HAS ADJOURNED.